verständlicherweise ist es vielen
menschen etwas zu gefährlich dann doch
in urlaub zu fahren weil am ende man
eben zu hause bleiben muss vielleicht
wie sind da jetzt also die regelung wenn
man seine reise doch noch studieren
möchte sowohl wenn man alleine gebucht
hat als auch eine pauschalreise also
moment haben wir ja die reisewarnung
außerhalb der eu und die
schengen-staaten oder schenken
assoziierten staaten haben wir noch bis
zum 31 08 und darüber hinaus ist sehr
schwer zu sehen was dann passiert wenn
ich also eine reise später gebucht habe
kann ich jetzt noch nicht kostenlos
stornieren wenn das von dieser
reisewarnung erfasst ist das
urlaubsgebiet dann kann ich kostenlos
stornieren bei pauschalreisen bei flügen
ist es ein bisschen anders da kommt es
darauf an ob der flug trotzdem
stattfindet oder nicht und ob der
anbieter sozusagen seine leistung
erbringen kann wenn der anbieter aber
seine leistung nicht erbringen kann
aufgrund behördlicher auflagen also der
flug ausfällt kriege ich mein geld
zurück